To test just how much attention...
...the attention-stealing design of the new Skoda Fabia actually steals,...
...we left one parked on this ordinary road in West London.
We wanted to see if its sharp, crystalline shapes, bold lines and lower wider profile...
...would attract the desired level of attention.
Will the 17-inch black alloy wheels stop passersby in their tracks?
Will the angular headlights attract the attention of other road users?
Will a crowd gather to check out its fresh, sporty look?
Well, not quite.
But did the attention-stealing design distract you from noticing...
...that the entire street has been changing right before your very eyes?
Don't believe us?
Have another look.
Did you spot the van change into a taxi?
How about the scooter change into a pair of bicycles?
Or the lady holding a pig?
Let alone the fact that the entire street is now completely different.
Didn't think so?
So, there we have it:...
...proof that the new Skoda Fabia is truly attention-stealing.